if you want to connect with people you
have to make them feel important hi I'm
Evan Carmichael and I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and if
you're trying to close a deal bring on
new customers lend investment capital
talk to the media build an awesome team
you have to connect with people and to
do that you have to make them feel
important everybody wants to talk about
themselves so stop talking about
yourself and start listening ask
questions ask them how they got started
ask them what gets him excited every day
make them feel important Mary Kay Ash
started Mary Kay Cosmetics from $5,000
in life savings and she started the
business up by herself she turned it
from nothing into a multi-billion dollar
company and when asked about her success
what led her to get to that
multi-billion dollar status she said one
thing she said she imagines that
everybody she meets has a sign around
their neck that says make me feel
important apply it to your business make
the people around you feel important
your suppliers your customers your
employees your investors the media even
your friends and family make them feel
important if you do and you apply it
it'll change both your business and your
life I hope you do good luck for those
of you watching if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes gonna do more for you guys and I
love to hear you have to think about
this video as always leave a comment
underneath I always read those I love
see them come in thank you and I'll see
you on the next episode
you